everyone went through this phase where
they were interested in boyfriends and
interested in being popular
i was like you guys disgust me i'm gonna
go hang out with my mom and when you
guys get a better head on your shoulders
we can reconvene
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
a girl who tried to do a red
under eyeliner once and then her teacher
asked her if her eyes were bleeding
elise morales
and with us today guys we have such a
funny comedian
she is an author she is one of the
co-hosts of the guys we [ __ ] podcast
but before all of that
she was a graduate of union high school
it's corinne fisher
i feel like i should come in in like my
mascot uniform from high school which
was a farmer
that's a farmer were you literally the
union farmer no
jesus christ no i was a baton twirler so
i was i was busy twirling while the but
but
i just think it's like out of all the
mascots one could have and it's not like
we lived in a farm town i mean you know
hundreds of years ago it was but
it's like very close to new york city
it's not
what if the mascot literally just like
a farmer in overalls with a
pitchfork uh would run around
yeah i feel like i've never heard of
that yep
you know we're unique that's good so i i
mean that is unique it is also funny to
think about like
a farmer fighting like a bear
right yeah you don't lose almost every
battle because it's human
to animal so yeah exactly and even the
other
human mascots are usually like the
warriors
right and someone who is fighting
someone
exactly this is just just a regular
farmer no no super
special powers or yeah nothing
are you from like the from jersey new
york area you said it's like near the
city
it's like 35 minutes outside of new york
city yeah okay
well i love that choice um so i always
love to start out by asking like
what flavor of high school was union
high school
uh it was very gosh i mean very
multicultural honestly
uh so it and it was kind of like those
you know 90s movies like can't hardly
wait
and stuff where you had actual like
specific groups like
the jocks the you know weirdo goth kids
uh
the kids who would just smoke outside on
an island uh
meaning an island of concrete not an
actual tropical island
um and you know theater kids and all
these kind of sections
i as usual was not part of any of the
groups though i've gone
pretty much throughout my life with
never being a part of a group even
though i am
heavily like involved in a group so i
know before we started
recording you were like i get a theater
school vibe yeah i was in all the plays
and like leads in most of them but i was
not
not really welcome i was like okayed in
that group
but i also didn't want to be in it
because you know i don't know i don't
want to be a theater kid
and the same thing with comedy like you
know i am a comedian but i'm not like
always hanging out with comedians my two
best friends are still
regular human beings so you were like my
involvement with the theater group
is professional it's not social yeah
just throughout my life i i'm i love to
be involved in things i love
doing things but i was there for the art
not for the camaraderie and that
that theme would travel throughout my
life well
i would say that the camaraderie of
the theater kids is like you really have
to be down to be into that
otherwise it's not a space you want to
be in
yeah it's also like a little bit
desperate a little bit thirsty i'm never
going to change anything about me to be
a part of a group therefore i'll
probably never be a part of a group
all right well like since we're on the
subject let's pull up i think your first
photo is actually a play photo
let's take a look at this one what play
are we working with here
so this is actually i was so into
theater that not only would i do
both the straight play and the musical
during the school year i would go to a
summer camp where i would do an
additional play so this is part of the
summer camp
and mostly only girls would be would do
this one
so this is an almost all female
production of guys and dolls in which i
played
um i played nicely nicely who sings you
know famously sit down you're rocking
the boat
on the one hand you're doing all these
shows i imagine that's and especially
since your
theater program you said was like really
good i imagine that's taking
yeah long time of your lifetime
so who was your social group like who
you said you know your friends your your
closer friends are the
normal non-comedian people now who were
your close friends then
i had three best friends who i basically
took throughout high school
um with me and two of them are featured
i think in that photo that you have
where
we're having like boas and we look like
we're at a forum
you know but whether it's just my
personality or because i'm a libra i am
like fiercely loyal so
the friends like so the girl on the on
uh the left
my left now my right in that photo is
the dark-haired girl
her name is paula and he's been my best
friend
since uh like end of sixth grade
uh until now you know i'm currently 35.
paula just had a baby she's married
we're still best friends
and so that kind of theme goes up
through my life the other girl with the
curly hair
her name's kellyanne and she was another
one of my best friends and then there
was another girl
named vicki who wasn't part of this
little performance on this day but was
part of our crew
and then one other girl actually named
tracy who i've been friends with since
high school
um but in that photo we were at my sweet
um and we had uh that group of three was
called the stis which of course stood
for
sexy uh i'm sorry this stds i was making
it too progressive
i'm sorry she went my progressive
sexuality brain just
cr edited that for me but back in the
day so we were called the stds
um which stood for sexy trio of divas
we had done a performance at my sweet 16
of
salt and peppers none of your business
um and that's why we were
that's why they had matching boas it was
my sweet 16 so i was in the gown
but that's what we were up to and we did
a lot of like so we were all
also these girls were also in the plays
with me but we kind of all just like
hung to ourselves and hung out together
on weekends
and we would like make weird movies in
my backyard and we
and you know kellyanne's uh uncle owned
a motel in wildwood that we would go to
every year for a week for free i was a
while with girl my family always did
wildwood for the summer i [ __ ] loved
it that's what was happening in that in
that part of my life and those were my
friends i'm always i'm always someone to
have like
a couple really close friends never a
big group of friends
a couple things that i'm getting from
this picture number one
this is a sexy trio of divas
you nailed it with the name uh number
two
i love did anyone else perform at your
sweet 16 or did
you just do a performance it was the
theme was las vegas so
um my i also one of my friends dressed
up as elvis
and also performed like i think in elvis
medley and i think that was it for the
actual performances
and then we had you know like vegas
style
games and kind of dances and stuff so do
you have like a
after-school job summer job no i just
it was stuff that i had saved from like
basically like every birthday
uh every you know thing everything that
happened i would get like a little check
here a little check there and i just
always saved it all um i was a big saver
when i was
little and then that's how i got to do
things like i went to space camp threw
myself a sweet
sweet 16 so a couple like big things but
i didn't have a job because i was so
busy with after school activities
that i didn't have time and the deal
that we had at home was like my mom's
like you just have to participate and be
busy i don't care if it's something that
makes money or doesn't
so i was always doing extracurriculars
and my brother
uh chose to get a job at the library and
make money because he wanted a car
though but i always knew i was moving to
new york city so i didn't need a car
all right so as far as you know your
podcast
guys we [ __ ] podcast i feel like i
gotta ask
what was your situation with boys at
this time are we dating are we [ __ ]
what's happening with them i don't date
her [ __ ]
in high school at all just not even i
mean i had one boyfriend actually i had
a boyfriend at the time of my sweet 16.
um but when i say i didn't i didn't date
anyone from my town because i was
absolutely disgusted
at the idea of dating someone from union
high school and the boyfriend i had at
that time
i had met in new york city um well i had
actually i had technically met him in
north carolina when i was an extra on
dawson's creek
oh my god that's where i had technically
met him
but it just happened that i have a thing
where kind of no matter where i am
in the in the america or in the world i
always gravitate towards east coast
people
so i just keep meeting new jersey philly
new york people over and over again no
matter i just i just it's a magnet i can
find them anywhere
um and so i met him like in
extras holding in wilmington north
carolina
and we just hit it off we spent a couple
days like just hanging out together on
set
and then uh continued um hanging out
when i was back in jersey and he was
back in new york city i would take the
train in and visit him and we were
dating
for like i mean i felt like a long time
but you know
it was high school so probably max six
months
you know yeah but at six months in high
school you're like this is the love of
my life
yeah yeah definitely i mean we if i got
i i think i threw some of them out
because they were just too
too much even though i know you're not
supposed to throw out old love letters
but like
we had some aol chats that would go all
night
some email exchanges that were very
passionate
oh my i mean truly like when i think
back to like some of those like
late night aim chats that i'd have with
a boy
it's like i don't know if i've ever like
bared
my soul to that level
to anyone in any other capacity
yeah i mean yeah this guy we were he was
a year younger than me
so he was 15 when i was 16 but uh we
were very like he was very adult i mean
he was also very wealthy
i have a history of also i think because
i don't care about other people having
money they
they also gravitate towards me so the
first couple of my boyfriends
and i'm talking about like not like a
little bit like like [ __ ] very rich
like
he was like his family was like new.com
money
um and he lived on like the upper west
side in this like
and i didn't understand you know how
much money you have to have to have like
a house sized apartment in new york city
okay and so i guess it didn't impress me
as much at the time but now looking back
on it i'm like this
kid lived in a multi-multi multi-million
dollar
um apartment on the upper west side and
i would visit him
there and you know he took me to places
like i remember he took me on a date to
cozy
which is you know just a sandwich place
but it felt very fancy
to me to get pizza at cozy which is not
even the thing to get
now knowing cozy um yeah i was like okay
first of all you got the pizza
he told me too
the upscale subway
yeah um do you feel like
what what do you think was the root of
you not being interested in boys at your
high school and
wanting this more like cosmopolitan
man experience uh i mean
you know i wouldn't think people were
cute but also i think it's mostly just
like the style
a lot of people were kind of in that i
i'm white but i dressed like a
rapper phase you know we all remember
that phase when people
put on you know fake dialects and stuff
and it was just
uncomfortable for us you know again back
to can't hardly wait big kenny fish
survives
um for everyone so uh
and i don't know and like they were just
like kind of immature
and i'm you know i was never someone who
thought it was like
fun or exciting for boys to be mean to
me
because i had self-esteem the whole time
uh
so i just like was completely not
interested and
i was you know i was more interested in
romance than sex and there's you know
i'm very always a very sexual person
like i remember my
the same you know sexy trio of divas and
i went to see cruel intentions in high
school and it rocked our world you know
we also studio 54 also came out during
that time
so there's a lot of these like really
sexual movies
um but you know when you watch a movie
like that you know the expectations that
you have for what sex and romance are
gonna be
are really high and also like really
drama-filled
yeah it's not i was just not scratching
that itch in any way with anyone who
presented themselves at um
uh union high school there was one guy
uh
lance that i had a crush on because he
looked kind of like
like somewhere between like the the
beast when he's the beast and the beast
when he's the prince
like stocky i like a stocky guy he had
longer hair
just you know quiet mysterious like
that's always my type to this day
first we don't know yeah
yeah like wasn't going to prom like as a
statement you know
these kinds of things and i remember
i like slipped in my number in the
hallway after like
lunch and you know in the cafeteria and
he actually called me
that and i couldn't believe it worked
because i was just like truly taking
techniques i
had found in movies that's how i was
learning everything
because the internet was still very new
so there wasn't a plethora of
information that there is now
um and uh we talked for like
two hours like a really long time and
then it kind of like fizzled from there
but we would
my friends and i would do things like
one time we made a fake pizza delivery
to his house just to get
to catch a glimpse of him um we like
dressed my friend gabe up
with like some kind of a fake gold chain
this is our vision of a pizza delivery
man i don't know
like a baseball cap and a fake gold
chain and i had
went to the recycling uh been in my
house and got in a pizza box and i was
like
you know and my friend gabe is like
walking up holding it this way dangling
and we're like the cheese is dripping
the cheese is dripping we're like
mine this better and paula and i were
like in the backseat of the car
looking over the window just to get a
glimpse of lance coming to
receive this fake pizza delivery and uh
stuff that we were doing and that was
like so much better than drugs or
alcohol like those are my fondest
memories
hello everyone today's episode of the
roast of your teenage self podcast is
brought to you
by magic spoon uh if you can't tell by
sort of the sleepiness in my voice
and the sleepiness all over my face and
the undoidness
of my hair uh i am coming at you right
first
first thing in the morning um and
[Music]
i don't have any magic spoon because i
ate all of my magic spoon
and i'm very sad about that because
magic spoon
it's the perfect way to start your day
friends it's got zero sugar 11 grams of
protein
and only three net grams of carbs in
each serving
so you get that full i'm a kid and i'm
having a bowl of cereal before going out
on my day
energy without the sugar crash
a bad bloating feeling hurting
tummy etc etc that comes along
with having a bowl of full sugar cereal
magic spoon also has four flavors
they've got cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry once again
hearkening back to your
favorite flavors of childhood
and it tastes amazing it's honestly too
good to be true it has no business being
as tasty as it actually
is it's keto friendly gluten-free grain
free
soy free low carb and gmo free
all of these things in one cereal it's
it's really
it's really truly incredible and i am
actually going
to purchase some more
when i'm done recording this ad speaking
of purchasing
magic spoon what do you think of that
segway that was pretty good
go to magicspoon.com roast and grab a
variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code roast
at checkout to get free shipping fun
fact
i'm going to use our promo code when i
go to buy more magic spoon
because it's like why not give back to
myself
in a way in these trying times you know
what i'm saying
so and magic spoon is so confident that
their product
is the best that it's backed by a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason
don't refund your money no questions
asked i'll just give you a refund
so that's magicspoon.com roast use the
code roast
for free shipping we thank magic spoon
for sponsoring this podcast
oh my god it's so early in the morning
and i'm trying on
where's my cereal
watch a glimpse of him like just to see
him
come to the door like so romantic i love
it i always
i'm like i'm very much of a voyeur
because i feel like when i get usually
get to know people they disappoint me
which is so sad um but i love kind of
just observing people for a long time
uh which sounds like scary but just to
see what they're like when
when when you're not around and like how
they exist i always found this to be
very interesting so
the picture i'm getting of you as a
teenager is like
the business woman at the beginning of a
rom-com who like
it's like like kathleen you haven't been
on a date in two years and she's like
i'm working on my company
yeah yeah i was very i'm like i have i
can certainly have a lot of fun but i'm
i've always been kind of adulty
like i always have i've always had a
plan i always have things to do
i'm not just like into like frivolous
silliness like
i don't know i just feel like there's
lots of things to get done why am i like
wasting time
i never went through a phase when i was
like out of control like my
for a good part of high school ever all
my friends were annoying me with my
image their immaturity so i was like
best friends with my mom
like i didn't care you're like
you're unserious like yeah i wasn't
because like when everyone went through
this phase where they were interested in
boyfriends and interested in being
popular
i was like you guys disgust me i'm gonna
go hang out with my mom and when you
guys get a better head on your shoulders
we can reconvene
that's so funny so how did you end up
being an extra on dawson's creek to walk
through that journey even scarier um my
my mom uh had a real
like obsession uh with the show and a
crush
uh on josh jackson who play famously
played
pacey winner on dawson's creek so much
so
that we she told us we were going on a
vacation to
wilmington north carolina which weird
choice but we were in a big vacation
family like i've never even laid in a
hammock until like two years ago
like we would always go to like this is
part of the reason why i'm no fun i talk
about it on stage but like i
we would always go on educational
vacations so like a true
an example of a real vacation the
fishers went on was to
the house where edgar allen poe wrote
the raven that was a real vacation
never been to an island never been out
of the cut i hadn't been i didn't go out
of the country until
uh until i graduated college and that
was because i begged my mom to go to
romania
um and yeah i just never
yeah i mean like the most tropical thing
was like disney world other than that it
was like
you know colonial williamsburg or you
know
museum a trip we're gonna go to three
museums
uh i think i convinced my mom to take me
to the andy warhol museum
so that was like a big win for me but i
mean still it was educational
um so yeah that that's what was going on
and then
my mom was very into like when uh aol
first started and there was like message
boards and stuff she got really obsessed
with the show dawson's creek
and would hang out on these message
boards and meet all these internet
friends which was fine because at the
time i had also during
all throughout high school which was
also taking up some of my time uh i was
the uh sole writer creator
uh editor of a weekly spice girls
newsletter called wannabe weekly
oh wow and i would spend legit i mean
five six seven eight nine ten hours a
week putting this together
it would come out saturday mornings
never missed a week like i was upset
like i was just
i was like this has to come out and i
and i would later meet
a couple people who were subscribers to
that easy and so it made me very happy
um but yeah my mom was obsessed with
austin screech she said we were going to
take a trip to wilmington north carolina
and kind of like midway through the
drive down there she tells me that i'm
going to be an extra on dawson's creek
even though that's not something i
asked for or wanted to do and she did it
i was like she like
manipulated me and tricked me into being
an
extra because i was the kid so they
needed kids for the high school scene
not adults so she could get
closer to josh jackson i mean this might
be
this might be a punishable offense in
some states
i mean it is it is crazy because when
you said
like when you were beginning this story
what i thought you were going to say is
that
you were a fan of dawson's creek i liked
the show but not that much i didn't need
to be on it you know
i'm enjoying it i assume that you
pursued this so to find out that it was
fully just your mom living vicariously
through you
yeah if you don't want to buy me she
tricked me tricked me in the car
packed tricked me
the catch is not only did this happen
once it happened again the next summer i
was tripped two times
were you on dawson's creek again
[Laughter]
okay well you know what into being an
extra on dawson's creek once shame on
you
but changing into being an expert on
dawson's creek twice
i was like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
i don't know i don't know it was
i was like are you kidding this is
because one time my brother was the
night the one time
i think one time it was just me and my
mom and then one time my brother was
there too
i believe was the boyfriend that you
eventually got was he a big dawson's
creek
person or was he just pursuing extra
work
i think the story with him was he was
just so
like his family was just rich and new
everyone so i think they were in the
area and it was like through a family
friend
see uh north carolina is a a right to
work state so it's a little bit easier
to be an extra and it was kind of just a
lot of locals signing up you didn't have
to go through the same
paperwork that you would have to go
through in a place like new york city
so it would kind of like you could just
put in a request because there wasn't so
many people
in wilmington that wanted to work on the
show that if you were coming to town
like the casting director would
make sure you got on um and it was fun
like i got to you know
be in a classroom scene with katie
holmes and that was like my big moment
because we were all in
extras casting and the director of the
episode came in and he scanned the room
and he chose me he was like this girl
needs to be in the classroom scene
and i was like i guess you can tell i'm
not from around here
that that's what was going down i don't
like being lied to
now so this actually based on the
picture of
your teenage self that i'm getting this
seems maybe like you wouldn't have done
it but did you try to parlay this into
any
popularity at school were you like oh by
the way i'm appearing on
creek is an extra or did you just like
lean back and let people spot you behind
katie holmes or not
uh i mean i told my friends and stuff it
became more of a funny story to tell
much later in my in my life at the time
i was just like
frustrated with my mom about it you know
especially because i always like i was
always annoyed because i was such a good
rule following you know a straight a
getting student
and and i would let her you know i would
let my parents know that i go you know
what other kids in the school really
being
acting like jackasses you don't know i
was like you don't know how good you got
it guys
and then also like as an older one like
on the flip side like
also like they just did a really
extraordinary job parenting and i had a
healthy home life which was why i was
behaving well so you know that also came
around and explained itself to me later
but at the time i was taking full credit
for how great i was yeah yeah you were
just like um i don't know if you guys
have noticed but i'm extremely mature
and well adjusted
uh you're welcome and it's like actually
the other way around
yeah we're i mean you said that you're a
rule follower
were you drinking or anything at all
during this time
were your friends uh the only time i
drank in high school was
there was a you know this the series
finale of sex in the city went down i
believe my senior year of high school
and i asked my mom if for the party that
we were having at my friend gabe's house
if i could have
a cocktail i asked her
and she said yes and we literally like
made it
we didn't have any of the stuff to all
we had was like alcohol and we found
like this
old mason jar in gabe's parents garage
that like had been used to like hold
like nuts and bolts and we emptied it
out and
we rinsed it out and that was like our
shaker like it was you know we made like
really makeshift cosmopolitans
and i had one drink and i had asked my
mom first so i just
i wasn't just i just wasn't interested i
was having a good time
like and i wasn't you know there was no
feelings i needed to mask like i just
there was no interest for me and my
friends i just have really
creative friends and we we we had so
many other things that we were doing
that it just never really came up
honestly so you said you and your
friends used to make like
videos etc were these like
kind of like sketch comedy like what was
your
we would do a lot of parody very into
like because i've always been
uh had my finger on the pulse of uh pop
culture been very into it so i remember
we did we made dawson's creek the
musical that was one summer we would
always have a production
and i was always the director we would
have something we would get all the
people
and like they would be like this would
be like going on for a week they'd be
reporting to set
daily baby my house like my mom just
knew there'd be some production going on
that would be shooting in my bedroom i
had a really big bedroom because i had
the attic
so um you know like a lot of people
could fit in there so we would shoot up
there
and then we would shoot in my backyard
uh and then you know maybe in the center
of town we would
do some shots but uh we did dawson
squeak the musical and then we did
the blair [ __ ] witch project because
that was kind of i mean that was a
groundbreaking film
uh when i was in high school it seemed
like easy for a bunch of
teenagers yeah parody because it's just
like
wasn't that well shot to begin with so
very good you run around you do the
close-up shot all that stuff
my friends did a breakfast club parody
called the mid-morning snack
club wish that i
still sometimes i wish that i had the
videos and then sometimes i'm like i'm
glad that they're gone and i can just
remember them in my head and be like oh
that one was so
funny and yeah actually watch it and be
like oh my god
[Laughter]
yeah i was doing a lot of like i i did
like a i remember i did a kind of a
you know wayne i was always everyone
always aspired to have a wayne's world
type
you know cable access tv show my friend
ellen and i did this
show called parte people where we were
just like
two ladies who loved to party and we
would let you know
how to party the best that was another
one because i had gotten a
i had gotten a a camcorder like a vh
with vh
uh sc tapes um so i could kind of like
piece things together and make
actual videos i was always kind of into
filmmaking which you know i went i
would later go on to get an actual bfa
in filmmaking
um but that was part of it and then
we would do like music video parties i
remember we did some like
uh destiny's child videos i posted that
on instagram a while ago
back in the day me and my friends used
to make videos we did
we made like this feature long film
at one point that we like wrote and made
all the characters
all of this stuff i mean it it didn't
make any sense we couldn't put it
anywhere because all of the music was
copyrighted
yeah yeah like it was but there's
something that was like so
pure about that time of like yeah
i'm gonna make a feature film
and put all my friends in it and now as
like
adults who are actually in the industry
it's like okay well i guess
if i want to make a feature film i have
to get in contact with this person
and try to get a green lit by this
person and i have to sell it and all
that stuff and it's like
it's kind of fun to think back to that
time where it's like no my summer
project is that i'm making a dawson's
creek musical with all of my friends and
we're going to shoot it in my attic
yeah yeah i was getting always getting a
lot of stuff done
nothing was in the way nothing holding
me back all right so let's
take a minute to go through the photos
of yours that we haven't looked at
yet is this one of your educational
vacations yeah i believe so i was trying
to remember i i picked this one more
because this shirt i'm wearing is
hilarious and like
um the i this was during a time when
it like my i think i was already in
college but i
because i was doing teen self as in like
actual teenage years and i was still i
was only 17 when i started college
but this was very early on and i was so
obsessed with dane cook
that like i act i had pictures of him
all around like my
dorm bed and i actually truly believed
in my head
that he would love me too if he just met
me like i was like
it's just it's only the fact that we
don't know each other that's keeping us
apart
100 fall for me and now actually having
met and knowing
and knowing dean cook a little bit i'm
not dean cook's type at all
so um that's absolutely very wrong on
that
literally but he he has been so nice and
i kind of told
i told this story i got to tell the
audience up in the main room at the
comedy store
about my like serious crush on dane cook
and he was backstage and he heard it
because i told it right before i brought
him on stage that was like a very full
circle moment
for me um and i was still embarrassed
to tell him but he was like very sweet
and like came on stage and gave me a hug
but like my friends made me an iron-on
shirt with dean cook and a heart and
then hearts around it
and i loved it um so that's why i picked
that but yeah i think we i think we're
in boston
and this is a statue around harvard
university um or in that area in the
boston area
um and uh
yeah this is just yeah i'm sure seeing
historical things
i don't even know i didn't sound like i
toured harvard
harvard or had any aspirations of going
there
so i don't know why we're there but yeah
um
so okay at this point you're in film
school you love dan cook you're
surrounded by images of dan cook are you
pursuing comedy at all or are you
still comedic filmmaking so i was i went
to the school of visual arts
um you know home basis 23rd street on in
new york city
um uh for you know to be a
filmmaking with a concentration in
directing
and uh yeah i was like there was only
two people
making uh comedic films and i was one of
them i always thought it was odd
that you know i went to film school i
thought everyone would be wanting to
make comedic films most people were
making
drama couple people made horror couple
me people made
uh comedy and so that was very
interesting to me but yeah so it was
always
comedic aspirations but in different
ways
all right let's talk about this one
this is we had a yearly halloween window
painting contest
in my town where you were just assigned
one of the businesses you got the whole
window they gave you paint and you could
do whatever you wanted and like
again i'm not super uh artistically
inclined so i would always try to make
mine
funny or like a little nod to pop
culture
survivor was very big at the time so
that's what i you know i've also done
like i did like
the spice ghouls one year like i just
like to do like a little pop culture
thing
and you know it's not so bad that you
can't tell what it is um
frankie votes at the tribal council for
those who are listening to the audio
version it's frankenstein
and he is voting at the tribal council
in a survivor type situation
i think it's very clear yeah yeah so i
would i would do that
i just loved anything where i could
somehow work more
on the weekends you know and that would
make anything fun not fun so i would
just be like
forcing myself to do this i don't even
know why i just loved i like i just had
a
real hunger to achieve things from a
young age
and and to like show your work to be
like and now
look look at what i came up with i bet
all of you dum-dums are drawing pumpkins
and i've created a whole world
here yeah i always wanted to be unique i
always wanted to
do something out of the box yeah and
like i you know as hard as i worked at
yeah i'm never one of those people who's
like
too humble to show it off or like oh no
i couldn't possibly it's like yeah no i
worked really hard on this so please
look at it
yeah this looks like it's another play
yeah this was a straight play so this is
kind of the example you can see how
intricate this
this set is and yeah part of it part of
being part of the
theater company was that anyone you see
on stage
uh also had to spend x amount of hours
working on building a set
um and the guy in the collared shirt uh
behind me that's steel burkhart who
would go on to be on broadway
um i was about to say the set for this
and the set for the other one is like
night and day
yeah because the other one was a summer
one so i mean we only have a couple
weeks to put that together and it was
also like
no air conditioning like for a in in
that school like it was like we were
really pushing it but this one
you know we would get this was like
where we were competing for awards and
this was a great play i think this was
bone chiller i believe my role was
eloise angsley i was an
older an older rich woman um
you know you can tell but you can tell
by my stance and my
business suit you're embodying it
you're putting forward the character
yeah i remember i'm
every episode of the podcast i talked
about the time that my school did wizard
of oz and i was glinda and
now is the time in this episode where
i'm going to do that but for when we did
wizard of oz
at my school we ordered these backdrops
from las vegas that were like
professional level we got like a flying
machine it was like crazy
we did like this crazy level production
the next year
we had run out of money and we could not
do that
because the teacher said that he was
retiring and then he did not retire
and just it's like there was no money so
this is the picture that i'm getting
of team kerwin like she's it's it's
really interesting because it seems like
you had a lot of confidence
it seems like you knew what you wanted
kind of no [ __ ] and um there's like
a maturity to
a lot of the stuff you're talking about
and the decisions that you were making
that is really
interesting to me so we actually have
one more picture
this is you know i i i my friends in my
hometown
uh gave me the nickname and it's fine
because i'm jewish um
halloween nazi and that is because
i made uh halloween so serious that of
course it was not fun for anyone else
um you know i mean i was taking costumes
very seriously
i was you know so this is in this
picture i am dressed up as
of course cindy lauper from her album
cover she's so unusual
another theme in my life was that i was
like doing things and knew about things
that
no one knew who the [ __ ] this was they
were like what are you an 80s girl i go
honestly i don't know who raised you or
what kind of an education you had but
i have no time for you so yeah i'm
actually a very specific
80s girl and i'm actually an ionic 80s
girl from an iconic 80s album
and you are ignorant yeah cause i was
like actually i nailed it piece by piece
i thought i was like if you compare this
to the cover of she's so unusual
the stance everything is there and the
fact that you don't know that just shows
me
that uh you had a a bad home life but
this is why you can't be dating the boys
at your high school this is why you have
to be dating the boy you met as an extra
dog
dawson's creek who lives in the city who
has some freaking culture
right now i needed some culture in my
life desperately i was like
i was kind of notoriously friends with
teachers like one of my best friends was
like my humanities teacher mr laird
i would just like go hang out with him
as he uh watched over chess club after
school
you know to get some real intellectual
conversation going on
so yeah exactly i feel like they're just
very
um like 13 going on 30 for your whole
life so at the end of the podcast
i always ask the same question i'm very
interested to hear your answer because
it does feel like
team corrine kind of had it going on a
little bit but
if you could speak to teenage corinne
today
what would you tell her great job like
honestly
i it's so funny because like with the
with the title of this podcast i was
kind of asking
i was like well okay like did i actually
have to you know like prepare rose jokes
about myself
because it's so funny like i don't
really you know the same
things that are roastable about me then
are still roastable about me now it's
not like i don't
acknowledge them but they also are like
the things that make me me so there's
nothing that i'm like
i'm ashamed of or embarrassed of like
it's definitely
funny but like i like
loved the life that i had and you know
because i think the things that we
regret are things that we
do to appease others and
i never did that i did exactly what i
wanted to the whole time they could like
you know even when my guidance counselor
was like you know
maybe you want to go and major in
liberal arts instead of
filmmaking because it's so specific i
just like said no along the way to
anyone
who you know i said no to everything
that like i just always
knew in my heart what i needed to do
what path i needed to follow
and i had no problem saying no to people
who would try to steer me in other
directions
and therefore like i just didn't have
any regrets really
so oh yeah damn that's so cool um well
corinne it's been amazing talking to you
uh this was so fun and for everyone
listening at home
this has been the roast of your teenage
self podcast
you